White House officials meet today with
technology and business leaders to
discuss the future of artificial
intelligence Google has already
announced plans to invest more in AI
research the company demonstrated new
technology called duplex at this week's
annual Developers Conference it enables
a virtual assistant to have a
conversation with a person over the
phone
duplex can be used to make restaurant
reservations and schedule appointments
many have taken note of how lifelike the
voice sounds at 12 p.m. we do not have a
quality available
but closest we have so that is a 115 do
you have anything between 10 a.m. and 12
p.m. depending on what service she would
like what service is she looking for
just a woman's haircut for now ok we
have a 10 o'clock can I am a sign CBS
News contributor Nicholas Thompson is
editor in chief of Wired Nick good
morning let me ask you this is is the
innovation here that the voice is so
lifelike those pauses are sound lifelike
or is there an innovation in artificial
intelligence here that's really moving
us torture closer to the actual brain
process ease of a human it's both right
because a it's incredibly lifelike sound
and that's based on the ability to
recreate voices and secondly the ability
to understand the context in those
responses and then figure out the right
response from that you know would you
like to do 1 p.m. okay well no how about
10:00 to 12:00 right it's a hard thing
to understand exactly what the person
you're talking to is saying so the fact
that the assistant can do that that's
amazing coding and what do we know about
all of us are familiar with auto correct
right you so I'm gonna be home at 12:00
and it says avocado right so is there a
or what we hearing the best of the best
the greatest hits of this working and is
it a little bit more bumpy than they're
suggesting it's more bumpy than they're
suggesting but the number of times that
autocorrect suggests avocado is
way less than a year ago this is
technology that is getting much better
very quickly so what we're seeing is
something that I thought we would see in
three years and we're seeing it now
because it's moving quickly I'm a little
creeped out by it though to tell you the
truth it's as John points out the
hesitations when she goes well one
o'clock and um because it really is
mimicking how we talked
shouldn't we be told that we're talking
to a robot so there's a good reason for
those arms which is that the machine is
processing information so you need to
pause just the way we do as humans but
you're completely right yes are you
creeped out by it there are all kinds of
creepy applications like you can imagine
like Martin shkreli getting a hold of
this and calling my mom to sell
pharmaceuticals at night right there are
all kinds of horrible things that can
happen with this but on the other hand I
was always saying don't bring me in this
country but I mean they're gonna think
about if I leave for work and I say you
know call Verizon based on whatever I
watch on TV and negotiate a better
package for me that would be amazing -
right so you can imagine all kinds of
uses that make your lives much better
and then all kinds of crazy
manipulations that can happen my
question is shouldn't we be told we're
talking to a robot yes I think that was
a mistake that Google made it
deliberately set this thing up to
manipulate the recipient to make them
think they're talking to another human I
think it should announce I am Gayle's
digital assistant yes and then have the
conversation but I don't think that they
should have had without that what about
smart compose something else
Google also unveiled yes so that's
another thing that's where you're
starting to write an email and it
completes the whole sentence it doesn't
just spell the word and that is
something again going back to John's
original question because of the sort of
improvements in semantic understanding
syntactic understanding and the ability
to parse what we're writing and it's
infinite knowledge of everything we want
and everything we type this is gonna be
really good but do you think this is a
good thing generally speaking overall I
think this is a good thing that will
lead to potential massive manipulation
like like the internet yeah like all
good say good thinning with some bad
sides all right Thank You Nick